et en fait il faut éviter d'avoir en
tout cas les fautes d'orthographe quand
on écrit un si on écrit un texto ou quoi
si c'est coucou ça va avec le S coucou
ça va euh bon voilà vraiment faut
vraiment faire attention à voir quand
même les rudiments de l'orthographe quoi
le truc ça c'est la première chose un
message vocale
on fait comment
notre vocal il faut il faut bien sûr
essayer d'avoir une voix une voix posée
mais une voix agréable on sait aussi que
la séduction
voilà donc oui il faut il faut changer
soigner de timbre de sa voix on sait que
les hommes qui sont considérés comme
viril et comme impactant auprès des
femmes et ça c'est culturellement
universel partout sont des hommes qui
ont une voix une voix forte puissante
si je veux pas voilà les femmes en
général on a des attentes plus pour les
aigus mais c'est vrai que depuis 50 ans
la voix des femmes c'est masculinisée et
les hommes aiment de plus en plus ça que
les femmes et une voix un peu plus loin
ça veut dire quoi un bon dragueur c'est
quoi c'est est-ce que c'est un homme qui
qui enchaîne les conquêtes et qui est un
peu
ou bien c'est un homme qui séduit les
femmes et qui les respectent bravo merci
Céline
et Raymond c'est la deuxième solution
parce que c'est un ami je sais alors on
va vous donner des des conseils ce soir
pour séduire des gens il faut avoir
confiance en soi
comment la personne le ressent que la
personne en face a confiance en elle
quel ne risque pas potentiellement
d'être déstabilisé par leur gare de
l'autre d'accord c'est à dire que même
si vous me regardez bizarrement mais je
vais quand même me dire non franchement
voilà t'inquiète voilà c'est ça même si
louche par là et tout t'inquiète
t'inquiète Audrey ça va tout va bien tu
es bien coiffé il a vu que tu avais
changé de coiffure et tout c'est nickel
voilà
[Rires]
merci merci merci merci Audrey merci
au naturel alors oui pourquoi parce que
souvent les gens tendance à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Guillaume on sort les quatre on peut
sortir
c'est un humour qui doit être
bienveillant un humour qui doit créer du
lien et c'est certainement pas un humour
qui doit en fait être au détriment du
récepteur exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
doit renvoyer une certaine forme de
légèreté les gens ont besoin de légèreté
dans la société dans laquelle on vit on
a besoin de on a besoin de s'amuser on
doit pas être 100% sérieux tout le temps
il est d'accord Cyril hein je vois qu'il
est d'accord
vous aimez bien
ça par exemple c'est une bonne technique
je rebondis
super pertinente merci en fait oui
simple les femmes ont besoin d'être
flattées de façon sincère qu'on
s'intéresse à elle sincèrement et donc
c'est vrai que voilà le fait que vous
parlez de mes boucles d'oreilles voilà
je me sens déjà je me sens déjà très
bien quoi
ah une technique on est on est on est on
est en TP on est en train de pratiquer
on vous montre ce qu'il faut faire et
pas faire oui mais comme ça vous avez
changé de coiffure oui un petit peu
voilà les femmes aiment bien qu'on
remarquement
vous l'aviez pas avant mais exact vous
êtes incroyable
mais oui c'est vrai c'est fou vous avez
vraiment un œil de lynx quoi exactement
ils aiment bien ça ou pas qu'on remarque
quelque chose ou peu importe c'est pour
les hommes chez les hommes c'est moins
important que chez les femmes les hommes
vont plus être soucieux de ce qu'ils
font donc qu'on leur fasse remarquer
qu'on apprécie ce qu'ils font merci de
m'avoir tenu la porte merci parce que on
parle alors on parle évidemment de la
galanterie toutes les femmes vont dire
ouais la galanterie c'est pas vrai les
femmes aiment encore les hommes galants
c'est encore une valeur qui est
importante dans nos dans notre vie
actuelle c'est d'avoir un homme qui est
qui fait preuve d'un peu de galanterie
un peu non mais sans déconner
vous êtes très bien élevé
avec qui d'être galon avec qui
moi
j'ai pas envie de le dire vous avez
quelque chose en tête oui
[Rires]
c'est mieux pour tous les deux c'est
mieux allez dégage
alors il faut également ne pas montrer
que l'on aime l'autre voilà
une petite part de suspense
c'est pas du genre le regard de Labrador
qu'elle a ah oui ah oui oui dis-moi ce
que tu veux je t'attends
il faut être prévoyant prévenant et
prévoyons aussi parce que si la meuf
elle va tomber va tu lui fais gaffe va
tomber
les meufs n'aiment pas les canards mais
c'est à dire que ça renvoie une petite
faiblesse et en fait homme comme femme
on a besoin d'être conquis et de
conquérir aussi
tout a l'air trop facile
par exemple
je suis foutu moi si c'est trop
facilement à qui en fait ça perd de son
prestige sa père de son aura nous sommes
comme ça
vous êtes d'accord avec tout ce que dit
Audrey vous n'êtes pas obligé
ça va moi je trouve ça beau quand la
personne dit ses sentiments moi je suis
pas du tout pour le jeu du chat et de la
souris il y a beaucoup de gens qui font
ça franchement je pense que 90 % des
couples font ça moi je déteste ça le
chat et la souris
oui ça dépend je vais rectifier ce que
faut pas faire ça pendant 15 rendez-vous
parce que si on m'endormir
si on sent qu'il y a pas directement
dans le jeu de la séduction
au début
dans la parade de Mickey non mais moi je
trouve ça insupportable le jeu du chat
quoi oui un chat oui non mais j'aime pas
les gens qui font attendre quand ils
répondent aux SMS etc qui font semblant
je pense qu'il faut dire à quelqu'un
quand la personne me plaît bah oui je
suis pas d'accord par exemple Cyril tu
m'excites
dans la séduction on va connait
il faut toucher subtilement la personne
alors oui toucher subtilement tout
dépend de la proxénie de la personne si
la personne elle est touchée faut pas
arriver comme un gros lourd à mettre sa
place
on effleureux
super allez-y super sympa que tu sois
passé vraiment
envie je veux vraiment que tu viennes le
8 mars
[Applaudissements]
au public
vous avez la question
d'un érotisme torique quoi donc
qu'est-ce que ça va être le 8 mars
vous êtes pas apesant
[Applaudissements]
j'ai très envie de
je te laisserai avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu connais pas du tout l'Amérique non
mais c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
là c'est très fort
attention
[Musique]
tu habites toute la journée
je connaissais un pote en Alsace
donc il faisait des cuisines
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo
à toi cette banane
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
en produisant subtilement la façon dont
les autres se déplacent nous pouvons
capter davantage l'attention des autres
c'est-à-dire que si la personne se
déplace un peu c'est comme ça
[Rires]
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
synchronisation des postures
on essaie de se déplacer comme la
personne qu'on veut
quand on est en face à face on reproduit
les mêmes gestes et en fait
[Rires]
il faut prendre soin de sa posture c'est
à dire tu vois on est on est sûr de soi
disons oui disons que voilà
ça c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
c'est la posture du mal à le faire là
c'est le mal alpha dominant très bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'est une caricature c'est
vraiment la caricature de la caricature
en fait voilà non la posture c'est être
à l'aise et se tenir droit de préférence
parfois on se rend compte que les
personnes qui sont très déprimées alors
je vois tout le monde qui commence
mais parfois nous quand on a on est on
est face aux épreuves de la vie on
parfois quand on nous prend en photo on
se rend compte qu'on est sur une chaise
comme ça bien sûr on a pris une mauvaise
nouvelle on est comme ça vous voyez
voilà on essaie voilà pas de façon trop
rigide parce que sinon c'est un côté
fake voilà c'est un côté voilà un
catégorie dans la brume côté voilà
du gorille argenté mais le côté voilà je
me tiendr droit
ne pas hésiter à varier le ton de sa
voix c'est à dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très content de faire ta connaissance
Qu'est-ce que tu bois
ah mais c'est vrai
puisqu'en fait en fonction des registres
sur lesquels on se positionne en fait
quand on parle on change le timbre de
voix si par exemple je suis en train de
m'enguerlandais avec mon fournisseur
d'énergie parce que ma facture a explosé
je vais pas dire allô bonjour je vais
dire allô je voudrais connaître ce qu'il
en est par rapport à cette facture je
vais rendre ma voix voilà
je vais rendre ma voix plus grave par
contre si j'apporte une boîte de
chocolat à Cyril je vais dire Cyril
voilà s'il vous plaît je vous ai ramené
une boîte de chocolat
ça va ça va et toi ça va très bien
[Applaudissements]
exactement
vous par exemple si vous offrez une
boîte de chocolat pour séduire quelqu'un
la voix que vous prenez s'il vous plaît
Cyril
salut Audrey
figure-toi que je pensais à toi et je
sais que ton péché mignon c'est
le chocolat
magnifique en plus mais les Manon au
café mes chocolats préférés Cyril
[Applaudissements]
es
en même temps
il a parfaitement intégré le truc
vous allez me prêter débile
c'est comme ça vous allez essayer de le
faire
au chocolat
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui mais ça va bien et toi
oui moi aussi moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
pour te couper la gorge
merci pour moi merci
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que éventuellement être
milliardaire ça peut aider pour pécho un
ami voilà un ami très proche
non ça peut aider ou pas ça dépend le
type de femme
on peut vivre d'amour et d'eau fraîcheur
c'est déjà ça super alors il faut
reconnaître ses peurs c'est à dire qu'on
est comme ça on est au restaurant
comme ça ouais ça marche
ça participe aussi de l'authenticité
d'être honnête avec soi-même de pas
voilà de pas dire oui j'adore faire du
vélo de course et tout puis finalement
on n'est jamais monté sur un vélo donc
quand on a certaines craintes faut pas
hésiter à les montrer à l'autre j'adore
les fruits secs et tout ça
reconnaître ses peurs
de se mettre en vulnérabilité par
rapport à l'autre les femmes aiment les
hommes un peu vulnérables pas trop alors
un subtil mélange de virilité de
vulnérabilité ça doit rester
alors lui il a beaucoup de vulnérabilité
c'est au niveau du chéquier surtout mais
non
moi je sentais une vulnérabilité
derrière le masque oui je sens je sens
que je sens que derrière le côté pitre
il y a une grande sensibilité
[Rires]
et enfin tu veux que je te dise là tu
vois là ça là je me reconnais ne pas
trop intellectualiser la relation
[Rires]
là on commence là
le problème c'est que souvent plutôt que
de vivre la relation telle qu'elle est
l'instant on va se projeter on va penser
à certaines choses dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose on va penser dix mille
fois à ce qui s'est passé de naissance
interprétation et donc en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est vraiment se dire je vis ce
moment et je l'intègre dans une relation
que je débute et je commence pas à
procrastiner à me poser 30 000 questions
puisque c'est l'avenir qui me dira si
cette relation a durable ou pas que je
commence à analyser il m'envoie un sms
il met 5 mots 10 mots 15 mots qu'est-ce
que je dois analyser de ça voilà donc il
faut vraiment essayer de se détacher de
ça c'est compliqué mais il faut vraiment
se dire je vis la relation telle qu'elle
se présente et c'est aussi un lâcher
prise une invitation lâcher prise parce
que j'ai dans une société contre lente
on veut tout contrôler
les hommes adorent ce numéro 10 j'ai
l'impression
que vous êtes en train de dire ça c'est
intéressant